I uh I want to emphasize one thing from
the very beginning of this debate there
have been many debates on Ukraine and uh
we all I think know now what we think
about it uh the war
um we on this side of the of the motion
are not discussing whether Russia was
right or wrong to invade Ukraine Uh
Russian Russian invasion of Ukraine was
an appalling aggression
I believe that it was wrong I believe
Ukraine was right in resisting it as it
is done I believe that NATO was right in
coming to Ukraine's Aid it was right to
give it military assistance it was also
right to be careful that that assistance
only went to Ukraine it did not stray
into Russia everything about the
military side of this war has in my view
been acted correctly from the West's
point of view so we're not discussing
the Rights and Wrongs of the war we're
discussing one a very specific thing
that is economic sanctions a quite
separate question from the war in my
view at least now sanctions ever since
the the second world war have been in
many ways the favorite weapon of more
liberal uh Western regimes
when they've been concerned to intervene
in the evils of the world wherever they
may be they have been on the whole uh
ineffective in that they haven't
achieved their goal and indeed Nicholas
Muller who's written one of the very few
books on sanctions it's an
extraordinarily neglected subject
he studied about 35 sanctions most of
them stood in place and he pointed out
that almost never did they achieve their
goal what they did was they were hurtful
so we're not arguing that sanctions
Don't Hurt You couldn't possibly argue
that and you looked at the history of
sanctions places like Iraq where the
most vicious sanctions were imposed
thousands of people probably died
through being denied medicines under
sanctions
um the UN has calculated that about a
third of the poor in the world are
operating or living under the cloud of
economic sanctions imposed by the West
they isolate regimes they entrenched
regimes they repress dissent they
bolster autocratic regimes in their
autocracy they are crippling of these
regimes but they don't seem to undermine
them and I think it's this inability to
undermine power that lies at the heart
of the ineffectiveness of sanctions
ineffective in not achieving their
political goal because they are a
political weapon
um never have sanctions
directly undermined the victim power
that they were intended to do it is
quite extraordinary Mulder in his book
assesses the effectiveness of sanctions
political Effectiveness or sanctions and
reaches to the conclusion that on the
whole they may have 20 percent
Effectiveness in achieving any political
goal at all in his book actually
describes the history of sanctions as
the history of disappointments simple as
that uh and then when you look at the
countries that were set I have been
sanctioned against uh Cuba North Korea
Iran Iraq Afghanistan Syria Myanmar
Venezuela all these countries have a
curious solidity about them some of them
were subsequently attacked militarily
but the sanctions never achieved their
goal of toppling the regime I think
probably if I was running an autocracy
I'd plead with the Americans sanction me
sanctioned me I I think probably that's
the surest way of achieving both
internal stability for my regime and
actually
um
security from being attacked outside
um it is it is it's the most bizarre
phenomenon that the most popular weapon
deployed by the West aggressively
against other countries should also be
the most ineffective it is a bizarre
thesis but it is the spaces on which
we're proposing this motion now um
one of the reasons for this I think is
that people misjudge the nature of
economic power and they think that and
largely these are people in the West in
capitalist countries they think that
money is part
curiously autocratic regimes but also
all regimes when they're in a state of
bellicosity when they're belligerent
um discard considerations of cost they
don't worry about the money it was very
noticeable even during the Faulkner's
War the British government
prevented Jeffrey Howe the chancellor of
the exchecker from ever attending a war
cabinet they didn't want him to come up
and say we can't afford it money was not
to be the issue when war is being fought
and this is so clearly the case I think
in in the in in the case of of fusion at
the moment
most of the countries that have
sanctions attached to them are small
poor states doesn't mean the sanctions
actions are effective it just means they
all have to be poor small states Russia
is probably the biggest and most
powerful state to have concerted
economic sanctions inflicted on it and
they have had the most extraordinary and
devastating sanctions inflicted on them
their problems one is that sanctions
always leak in the case of Russia
sanctions of elite to Iran and China
helping it in in the one as you respect
in which they needed help particularly
with a small equipment for their weapons
but the real problem is that Russia also
has power to hit back
now I'm told that nobody ever in the
course of the planning of British
assistance to Ukraine ever discussed
what might be the consequence of
sanctions against Russia for Britain
they just didn't think of it because
sanctions are so natural the response to
any uh a conflict that they simply don't
worry about what might be the effect or
the ineffectiveness of them
Russia does have the power to hurt the
worst with gas and oil sanctions and
with other raw materials and it did not
propose to do that at the beginning of
this war but it did react to the
Declaration of economic sanctions
against it in other words this separate
War the war the economic war with Russia
is quite separate from the war about
Ukraine it is actually a war declared by
the West collectively against Russia
although it was not prepared to declare
war against Russia military as a result
of which Russia could fight back more
effectively I think he's been able to
fight back militarily in Ukraine
um indeed I think and I'm pretty sure no
one ever predicted the degree of
instability that Russian reaction to
sanctions has inflicted on the west I'm
almost tempted to say that if I was
trying to propose a motion the sanctions
against the West might work
um uh because of the of the effect that
these sanctions have had on the west I
might be much more difficult much more
difficulty arguing the case
um sanctions on the west have been
extraordinarily effective because
look at Donald Trump's Fallen Boris
Johnson's Fallen this trust has fallen
um the the the the German and French and
Italian governments have been
destabilized
um the effect of the sanctions on Russia
um in response to them has really been
devastating uh probably the cost of the
sanctions to the West has been much
greater than the cost of supporting
Ukraine militarily
so you do have a situation in which you
have to say what on Earth was the point
of this exercise the sanctions aren't
effective they aren't uh they aren't um
hurting Russia they're hurting Russia
but they aren't affecting Russian
decisions over the war pigeon is
peculiarly resistant to any um
thing the West does in in in in in the
way in which he conducts this war
um when in 2004 the sanctions were first
imposed
um the the sanctions were described as
deterring him from going any further in
Ukraine they were conspicuously
unsuccessful in that respect and I have
to say that that um that in the in the
case of the sanctions which were imposed
on him the only response that the West
could do when criticized for those
sanctions was to say well we couldn't
think of anything else to do and anyway
maybe we didn't impose them severely
enough well we've now imposed them even
more severely indeed the most severe
sanctions ever in history and they're
still not worked in deterring Beauty in
from the most horrific crimes in the
Crimea in in Ukraine
now all like all I can do in conclusion
is is um is point out that the um the
opponents of us in this motion
um are uh dealt with us in this subject
with some detail
um uh Owen Matthews here has written
about this extensively an excellent book
which I strongly recommend you all to
buy
um it's about the Russian response to uh
to the Ukrainian war and written very
boldly in the middle of the war rather
than waiting for it to end but he says
in the book very clearly sanctions did
not work in deterring Russia from going
further after they invaded donbass and I
have afraid to quote him saying of
sanctions now where he says the fact is
that Kremlin fears neither a backlash
from an elite
nor from the people of Russia over the
economic decline imposed by sanctions
things would have to get far far worse
worse than ever in living memory for an
angry silent Russian middle class to
contemplate regime change
indeed Owen does say it's an excellent
book I want you to know it does say that
the uh the consequence of pujin being
toppled which is one of the putative
consequences of the sanctions of him
being probably the worse regime in
Moscow than having peace in there and it
is not wise policy at the moment to hope
for Putin to go the people who take over
from me are far worse
we have a problem now how do we end the
sanctions
it's a curious fact of sanctions so
easily imposed that they are the most
difficult to end I think there's about a
hundred sanctions regimes operating
around the world now mostly out of
Washington
okay uh and the the answer to that is um
that they don't end easily they end with
great difficulty and often not at all we
can have a big problem in ending these
sanctions I want you to know they hurt
but they don't work thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
our first speaker thank you very much
I'm now going to invite Anna Reed to
speak Anna as a historian and journalist
she was cave correspondent for The
Economist and the Daily Telegraph in the
early 90s and is the author of
borderlander Journey Through the history
of Ukraine uh the fourth edition of
which has just been published and as
other books are the Shaman's coat a
colonial history of Siberia and
Leningrad tragedy of a city under siege
1941-44 which was shortlisted for the
duff Cooper prize it's been translated
into 17 languages and is just going into
Romanian so still spreading from 2002 to
six Anna directed the think tank policy
exchanges Foreign Affairs program she is
a trustee of the Ukrainian Institute
here in London Anna you're 10 minutes
thank you
so
um are sanctions working or not they are
working
right now they're helping Ukraine to
defend itself and hopefully to win the
war
longer term they will restrict the
growth of the Russian economy which will
in turn restrict Putin's ability to wage
more Wars making us all safer
whether we like it or not while he
remains in power we are back at Cold War
style containment
the sanctions should stay in place we
need to make sure they're enforced
because as Simon Says historically
they're evaded
and ideally we need to make them
stronger
Richard's The Economist here so I won't
go into detail on the sanctions
themselves or their economic effects but
in brief
the West response to the invasion in
February was remarkably unexpectedly
strong and Swift and unified there was
near Universal condemnation in the U.N
weapons started to be shipped
immediately
and the first package of sanctions was
agreed and I think we're now on to our
sixth seventh package I've lost count
they they were on a completely different
scale
from the smear slap on the wrist
in terms of sanctions that the West gave
Russia in 2014 after it initially
invaded the Don bass and Crimea
they cover hundreds of state-connected
individuals and entities who've had the
assets abroad Frozen doing business with
them is banned and they've been slapped
with travel bans that list is still
expanding
on the financial side all but essential
Financial transactions with a very small
number of Russian banks are banned
Russian banks are out of the Swift
International payment system credit
cards issued by Russian Banks don't work
abroad in addition the portion of
Russia's Foreign Exchange Reserve held
in central banks abroad has been frozen
and that makes up about half of the
total Russian Reserve
on trade export to Russia of a wide
range of goods sensitive ones and high
technology products in particular is
banned it includes micro microchips
vitally on the import side Europe is
dramatically cutting its purchases of
gas and oil on the gas there was
originally a rather vague plan never
laid out in detail to cut down on
purchases but Russia jumped the gun by
itself first turning off the Taps using
the need for maintenance of the of the
Nordstrom pipeline as an excuse and then
it actually sabotaged
extraordinarily the two Nordstrom
pipelines itself
so you're you're prevented from buying
more Russian gas willy-nilly
on oil the sanctions have not yet come
into Force they'll do that next month
from December the 5th
Imports of Russian seaborne Imports of
Russian crude will come to an end and
that will be extended in February to all
oil products
the G7 is putting together a price cap
on Russian oil the details of that have
not yet been announced but that will
come into a force also next month last
of all over a thousand Western firms
under pressure from customers in part
have voluntarily withdrawn from Russia
either closing or selling up completely
or mothballing operations
more firms have halted investment plans
so however this this message massive
package of sanctions have affected the
Russian economy so far
when they were first announced there was
when the war broke out there was Panic
shelves emptied ATMs more or less
stopped working the ruble crashed since
then things have stabilized but only
superficially shelves are full again but
with substitute more expensive Goods
inflation's running at nearly 13
rubles recovered but thanks to exchange
controls and the facts that Imports have
collapsed
on the all-important question of energy
prices they're coming down again the gas
prices coming down again after its spike
in the summer thanks to some rather
Nimble
um finding of alternative sources of
Supply by Europe and oil is down to 87 a
barrel So Below the magic 100 a barrel
which is in normal times the the level
at which Russia can balance its budget
that's partly due to another fears of
another covert break outbreak in China
but also due to this imminent G7 price
cap
the Russian economy as a whole is
forecast to shrink by over three percent
this year over two percent next those
are disappointingly small figures but
they mask much bigger drops in sectors
dependent on Imports so high-tech
manufacturing telecoms Aviation
High-Speed Rail and vitally defense
so how is all this helping Ukraine win
the war
the the the extremely important direct
and immediate way the sanctions are
helping Ukraine is by preventing Russia
from rearming
so in these first nine months of its
suicidal unprovoked War it suffered
enormous losses of military kit perhaps
two to three thousand tanks five to six
thousand on on apcs hundreds of
artillery pieces and aircraft
it still has lots of dumb unguided
Soviet era shells left but it's running
out of smart modern missiles
Ukraine's defense Ministry reports that
captured Russian weapons have used
cannibalized spare parts from other
weapon systems and sometimes even
Electronics borrowed from you know
consumer white goods
another indicator of sanctions how
sanctions are hobbling Russians arms
manufacturing is that Russia's having to
buy weapons from Pariah States drones
from Iran guided shells according to us
intelligence from North Korea
longer term most economists agree that
Russia is set for stagnation you know
sort of skimming through various reports
you know the words that crop up are sort
of dismal chronically sick
impoverishment
and that that is set to continue
irrespective of sanctions even if we
left if even if we lifted sanctions
tomorrow the West would still be
diversifying away from Russian
Commodities you know the permanent loss
of gas sales to Europe will seriously
hit government government revenues China
will not make up the shortfall even if
it were willing to the infrastructure
doesn't exist the necessary pipelines
don't exist
Russia's lost access to International
Capital markets foreign investors have
been put off for perhaps a generation
and it's losing its own best and
brightest Minds as educated young people
flee because they don't want to be part
of Putin world and they don't want to be
conscripted
another point that the Economist Tim Ash
long long term time Russia and Ukraine
Watcher with bear stones
um puts is that while Putin stays in
power unless he moderates his militarism
which he shows no sign of doing Russia
is stuck in an arms race with the West
and has happened for the late period
Soviet Union that will bankrupt it
you know something Western policy makers
ought to say to themselves three times
every morning in the mirror is Russia's
economy is only slightly larger than
Spain's
you know for all its imposing vastness
on the map and it's ridiculously
overblown sense of its own importance
Russia is not a great power
you know U.S defense spending alone this
year will be over 700 billion dollars
that's nearly half of Russia's entire
annual GDP
if all the NATO countries step up and
fulfill their promise to up defense
spending to two percent of their gdps
Russia will be outgunned even further
you know all this will not necessarily
mean a moderation of Putin's aggression
nor will it necessarily mean he's
shuffled aside by the elite or that
there's any sort of popular mass
movement against him Owen's going to
talk about the effect of the war on
Russian Society
but it contains Putin it reduces his
danger to us
it reduces his room for maneuver and I
think you know that may be for the
foreseeable future the best that we can
hope for but it's still certainly worth
the price
in conclusion to get back to our motion
our sanctions against Russia working yes
they're helping Ukraine to win by
hampering Russian arms production yes
they're making Europe more secure by
forcing us to end our dependency on
Russian energy yes they'll weaken Russia
economically long term which while the
current regime stays in place makes us
all safer
let me pose a counterfactual to sum up
Russia Russia Simon's argument is that
sanctions should be discontinued and
Military Support for Ukraine continued
um in other words energy purchases
should resume at the same time that
we're sending arms to Ukraine first of
all that would incred that would
embolden the Kremlin that would send a
signal to the Kremlin that plays that
that we're losing interest that we're
going to give up on Ukraine it plays
also straight into their narrative that
the West is hypocritical decadent week
it would encourage the Kremlin to carry
on with the war second it's not tenable
at home you it's it's simply too
incoherent a policy to to to keep it up
it's unsustainable politically
domestically
third lifting sanctions would harm
relations with Ukraine it would
completely undermine Ukrainian morale
and it would undermine a country which
is a vital buffer state for us I'll come
back to it more when we have our extra
minute at the end
you know this is we're helping fellow
Europeans this isn't a this isn't a this
isn't a it isn't a repeat of Iraq or
Afghanistan we're not you know we're not
invading Ukraine we're not setting off
another civil war we're defending fellow
Europeans
um helping them defend themselves that
they can carry on with a way of life and
rights that we take for granted
um you know they don't want to be part
of Putin's crazy stalinist fascist sort
of Orthodox mystical mashup dream world
you know the big the big picture is very
simple and so is the answer to this
motion thank you
[Applause]